alte arbeiteten hier ist eine offene tür
also die können einfach wieder raus
laufen ich drückte jetzt nach osten die
pille loris kommt freude hat nicht
geklappt und supreme der also
sehbehindert ist und dass gerade ich
sehen kann hier habe gerade sieben
baracoa felix im chat geschrieben in
betrieb bleibt ist das nicht so traurig
weil ich hab einfach fast gar nichts es
macht mich allerdings dass zweiten wir
das bad mit traurigen ein jammern appell
der nachhall verschmiert war halo weißt
du das ist ein dia ich bitte dich von
yoga nötig erst mal leise zeug heißt
nicht dass er trotzdem halt weniger
selten ist
ich habe halt nur hier den trick wie man
es aushalten oder einem us-gericht
ansonsten aktion luca und dann gibt's
die schnelle links und rechts ich kann
aber kommen und auf nämlich und wehrheim
gefragt in real life einfach eine rein
schlagende stadt durch die facebook vor
vom steten hier bitte immer noch nicht
losgelaufen stimmt ja zuschauer
vergriffen
wieso wie komme ich denn jetzt
eigentlich rein bin ich dumm ich hab ihn
weggefährten eingebaut mit erde
frag mich ganz einfach bei der ganzen
erde ist vollkommen schöner eingang sind
das soll gut in der schlucht ich kann
jetzt einfach hingehen source und kann
die wasser spots zu bauen kann
genau ein jetpack of link ach hier bin
ich hier war ich schon mal ich habe mich
leider bloß stecken
ich habe meine höhle drin gesteckt und
habe kein spielzeug mehr habt kommt noch
keine machen muss ich mit der faust
raushauen
also genau hier an der stelle will ich
das weiß ich noch da so zu sagen ja ich
hab dann weg noch zurückgefunden aber
ich sage mal kurz ein bisschen obsidian
ist also ihr lover sich besondere dem
zauberstab den block austausch getroffen
habt ihr erst mal hier
schön dass obsidian eingesammelt das
natürlich sicher 31 oxidieren das recht
schon mal für drei portale
ich find's lustig bitte ich habe bitte
gesagt bist du denkst du willst du sonst
jemanden rauswählen aspekt diamanten
dann sind alle guckt mich an was ich
habe hat er gesagt ich brauche es steckt
ja man da hab ich aber da nicht bitte
gesagt ja also so eine aussage jetzt
irgendeine ankommt und sagte ich das
schon gut du kriegst was okay jetzt muss
ich jetzt mal ein bisschen bauen
irgendwie hab ich gar keine motivation
und ausgebaut weil ich einfach nicht
ich könnte
ja ja einfach einen dirt haus bauen
das wollte einen schlechten witz im ganz
schlechten bitte die straßen denn ich
simon erzählt
ach so ich dachte jetzt mal raus ist
dein haus was ist weiß anstatt beim
essen
diese lawine mit einem lächeln der
beiden gesicht du kanntest den schon
locker ach ja schön ist dass haben so
nochmal die zuschauer hier seht ihr egal
lächelte bei gesicht kann ich hier nie
sagen ist eine volle ins die kamera so
ruhig ob sie da aber keiner hat jemand
lächeln gesehen
die bande war nicht gut heute anderer
kassen am meisten jetzt holt der
schlechte witze über die adelberg hessen
am meisten maurer die verputzen ganze
häuser das war nicht mein witz von
schlachten älteste habt ihr gehört wie
ich mit meiner hand gegen die stirn
geschlagen haben
nein hab ich leider nicht aber ich
versuche rädern darauf kann man sich
schnell das intro wenn ich als blöd bin
und das vergessen
welcher haase trotzdem nicht vom dreier
zu springen brasilia ich habe selber
nicht mal gelacht ja ich hab's aus
mettlach mutter hat das mach ich denn
jetzt eigentlich
ich ganz ehrlich sagen
du musst tun was ein mann tun muss und
support jahrhundert was ist mit gott
diese wie das immer hinter interpretiert
wird
meine güte so ich glaube du hast so was
mache ich denn jetzt überhaupt ich weiß
gar nicht ich habe so viel babel wieder
und es ist aber so ruhig hier einfach
ohne den ganzen regen ist es unglaublich
ich gehe jetzt immer verschiedene mit
einem fisch verabschiedet sich
verschiedene mich mit einem tollen flach
biz in hamburg wurde am ufer einen sarg
gefunden konnte man aber nicht öffnen
war wohl ein zuhälter drin so einfach
jetzt aber wie ich mir ein haus bauen
soll ja das kannst du dir selbst
überlegen ich mache das ja du hast ja
marvel briggs genossen markus brzenska
selbst überlegen
der mann soll ich denn sagen soll ich
dir die ganze arbeit abnehmen oder was
weiß ich sollte jetzt die russische
hauptstadt der wiederaufbau soll ich
nicht gleich finde ich die folgen
aufnehmen und ihr dann schicken sie
schenken ich werde jetzt hier ganz
hoffnungsvoll
nein ich wollte mir gefällt mir hier so
ein scheiß baumbusch axel den punkt sie
abbauen
ihren job richtig fetter bobic ist so
danach brauche ich dann hier ein haus in
freude so danach beschäftige ich mich
mit fließt das heißt sich programmchef
vorbei und die kugel weissberg vorbei in
den folgen die sparkle hat aber halt
dingsbums komme aber alle noch ja ich
gucke dann einfach wieder ins lot oder
ich schaue einfach hier bei ihm auf dem
grundstück vorbei das mental visser
weise fünf partner frank hochzuladen das
heißt sie müssten zügig kommen
sollte man nicht verpassen ja ich habe
heute auch schon gefahren bei mir ist
ein paar am tag entstanden also bis zum
video so weit bin ich nicht auch bin ich
trotzdem auf den baum um baum so
freundlich bereits erstmalig wollte erst
mal nur einen kleinen raum und dann
werde ich das nach und nach einfach
alles ergänzen da sollte es war keiner
was sagen
das heißt also wenn ihr jetzt sagte
hofreiter ja ich weiß braucht wirklich
solltest du ein bisschen gucken das so
bei den materialien so viele
verschiedene wie möglich nimmst
ansonsten wird's halt irgendwie eintönig
und monoton aussehen muss immer beim
bauen
knapp 10.000 maschinen sachen nehmen
dann was war und was noch gut aussehen
ordnung drin haben aber ich meine das
gleiche sein also jetzt nun weiter mit
diesem mar buildings machen dass wir
irgendwie nicht so gut an die wand
mitmachen aber so ich mache mir noch so
eine hecke nicht person mag es heute ein
bisschen osmanischen holz doch die
golfplatz und ein volleyballfeld es denn
gerne das ist ja muss ja meint auer
stabile letztes automatisch schon da
das hat sich wieder so bei dir an das
kann ich auch
holz und kohle der teil habe ich so viel
aber
dass ich noch
also wie gesagt es ist erstmal eine
kleine hütte
ich brauche ich auch gar kein haus
gerade ne also ich hab jetzt auf jeden
fall die grundlage und das war's dann
bewusst fürs erste jedenfalls mal
hinkriegen das flugzeugessen asthma und
auch wenn ganz ohne dass du die ganze
zeit stirbst wegen den ganzen mopsen so
dass erstmals das reicht eigentlich in
dem grundstück nimmst und das
ausleuchten oder fackeln habe ich auch
gemacht schon chance porter keine sau
mehr
ich habe jetzt erst mal ein bisschen
schafe dafür die schere deshalb hat eine
schere dies komplett leer aber ich habe
einfach keine volle hast du das
hingekriegt war et abgebaut
wahrscheinlich blätter ach ja bis man
ein gutes natürlich gesehen das war als
10 a ligen zur vermutung liter okay ich
gehe jetzt auf schatzsuche und ich hab
keinen hut wird das heißt ich kann auch
keine schweine oder irgend sowas holen
ich glaube ich werde mich einfach nur
von gebratenen stakes erlernen
und ja das gibt es das läuft nicht so
führung nicht rum es sein dass der in
form von schweinen
er hat natürlich eine schweizerin wie
soll ich das ansonsten kriegen
naja ich meine du kannst auf die gegend
laufen die ganz einfach die stakes
zusammenfahren alles töten aber
wahrscheinlich über eine tiere lehrer
gegend manchmal die folglich tiere
diesen dialog uhr
ja das ist mir aufgefallen ist einfach
kreative wäre ich glaube ich werde ich
habe zum glück ein paar hühner bei mir
ich hab so ein kleiner grüner farbe
ich brauche nun definitiv erst mal
schweiz sei die sind auf seinem
grundstück ja da kannst nix machen dann
wird er die vielleicht nicht gesammelt
haben uns dann gezüchteter museum alte
arbeiter hier ist eine offene tür also
die können einfach daraus laufe ich
drück dir sagt loris kaum freude ja
kann sich auch mit karotten walken und
laufen sagte ich zu sein dass die
karotten gegessen alle nein das geht
nicht mehr seiner neuesten geht schweine
nur noch mit 16 ja karten etwa karotten
ich weiß noch dass dir also seit
einführung der karotten muss man die
trockenen orten züchten
ich bin bei fast 26 diamanten 60
verschaffte nennt ist ein dorf ja da
waren auch doch da war der ball drin
der letzte gang jetzt durch laufbahn
habe ich echt genug also erstehen die
kiste darunter alice lehrer so also
dieser war definitiv auch schon leute da
hinten ligatoren da war auch schon
welche mittels der fast alle
ich bin ja gerade mittendrin unter der
erde kann auch die höhlen sehen die den
namen gemacht mit seiner mining turtle
wir sind als meine chefs und den hass
schlechte wert auch schon auch nicht
ausgerufen hier der karte sieht man
jetzt hier zu schaffen gemacht karte
sixt da alexander ist ein buchladen eins
zwei drei vier gänge
der tunnel ist der vulkan machen will
kann da kann man sterben ball dann aber
raus kommt da oben war ich auch schon
die kiste weiß nicht ob noch kisten sind
aufrücken
ich habe dann finde ich hoch aber kann
ich mal gucken schicken so rein klingt
es auch cool in den brunnen sind
teilweise auch mal teilweise diamanten
gold und in brunnen getauchte diamanten
drin so ein wildgewordener brunnen
siehst kannst mal gucken wenn dann
jemand um drin und gold auch aber dass
das noch fallen das heißt die schnappen
dazu und dann kommt aber von oben
deshalb wird die man schon gesehen dass
der links- oder falle gelaufen ist habe
ich den übelsten vorteil wegen im jet
pack kann der verein fliegen wieder
rausfliegen und ich kann mit dieser
tausch zauberstab einfach mit dem blog
tauschen das heißt ich kann einfach dann
hingehen richtig drauf machen dann wird
das durch kopien ersetzt das gold zum
inventar und das was die blöcke halt
durch steine ersetzt worden das heißt
die falle wird nicht ausgelöst weil der
block endlich abgebaut wo
das richtig reden x-beliebigen blog
einfach durch jedes jede andere
beliebige blog ersetzen genauso angst
ein ganzer block ist also diamanti
richtigkeit und den eingehen und die
können seine diamanten ochsenkopf
verwandeln aber da hätte er natürlich
viel koppel stones aus meinem im delta
da liegen und ich seine vier diamant
blöcke in meinem bett drin
wir können einfach bei der diamant block
ab und sagen das war ein ende weil das
wird einfach jeder sehen und jeder wird
dass die fetzen
weil ich ich auf die ganze zeit und
alles ist einfach schon erkundet was
halt features machen kann man damit
holen aber sein vertrauen damit hatte
ich weiß ihr digitale stadt bleiben ja
doch ich mache das jetzt so viele
kollegen welche wären schon mit kommt
ihr da draußen haben und sorgt man für
ist mein diamanten kiste reinkommen und
jetzt habe ich insgesamt nicht so arm so
ein bisschen knapp bei kasse und die
folgewoche wieder voll bei mich bei 20
minuten muss erstmal cut machen und dann
sehen wir uns der nächsten folge dank
fürs zuschauen
ok moment wenn wir sind immer noch in
der alten wahrscheinlich so lasst euch
davon nicht irritieren
aber ich glaube ich es vielleicht noch
was also bleibt irgendwas in seinem
zimmer irgendwie ich bin da ich kann ich
gleich wieder loslegen 321 jetzt so
hallo an alle zur nächsten folge des
mega projektes zusammen mit luca immer
noch sagt hey ich bin gerade mit vier
kühen in eine grube gefallen voller sand
und ich komm ich raus
ich hole mir grad kühl ich habe 276
diamanten hier gerade den profi als
existent wird also du kriegst auf jeden
fall was abschluss ist schon mal klar
komplett kommt mit alle ein hast du
schon bekommen habe ich schon bestimmt
so doch noch recht behinderter und die
konflikte jetzt alle vier leute haben
wir so die kühe sollen standhalten
komplett ruhig